- Welcome.
I'm Olen Ronning
and I am a Director of
Product at Smartsheet
and I'm gonna be talking
about how we're bringing AI
to increase visibility
into your Project and
Portfolio Management.
Before we dive into all of
that, just a quick intro.
Who the heck is Olen?
Kind of by the numbers.
I've been at Smartsheet for six years
and I've spent a bunch of time in product.
Before that, I was a designer.
And I studied a combination
of Computer Science and Industrial Design.
And I still scratch the itch
on industrial design
once a year for Halloween
and build these kind of displays
of different movie themes.
Can anyone guess what this movie theme is
for this year's Halloween?
Hear it?
Louder. "Tron."
Yes indeed. It's "Tron."
So, I use this, a note
from before where I,
I love this quote from
Steve Jobs he used to,
said many years ago of he saw computers
as a bicycle for the mind.
And I think about AI is like
a lightcycle for the mind.
It's just gonna go so much faster
and get you even farther than ever before.
So, let's talk a little bit
about how does that apply to portfolios?
How many people here are
managing projects or portfolios?
Show of hands.
Okay, cool.
How many, I'm gonna ask you,
if you look across your portfolio,
I'm using this frame of
seeing into the void, right?
There's so much out there.
When you think about
managing those projects,
managing those portfolios,
how many of these things
resonate with you?
Anybody? Is it?
Does this resonate in terms of issues
and things that you're trying to do?
Is there something that's not on this list
that should be on this list?
Yeah? Kinda matches.
Again, kinda side head nods.
So, what we're thinking
about is how can we leverage
the power of work management
tools coupled with AI
to make it so much easier to
get to those insights faster
and ahead of time, and more proactively
rather than reactively.
And so, when we think about like,
what are the specific challenges
related to the ability
to kind of dig up those
insights, identify risks?
There's a couple different factors
that come into play there.
So, one is obviously
the lack of visibility.
And that visibility is both into,
like, what's going on in the work,
what's the current status of it,
who's working on what, what
are the resourcing availability
of the teams to do the work
that we're trying to do?
And having to constantly
do all those things
we just saw on the last slide
where we're trying to hunt
down the different updates
and statuses and things like that.
It means that you're working off of data
that's not up-to-date or
you're constantly spending
a bunch of time tracking it down,
and then you're missing
risks and work gets delayed,
and the actions to mitigate
those risks come too late
before they can actually
have an impact, right?
The other thing that we see is
that a lot of people who are,
maybe this resonates with you
where you're managing a portfolio,
you have a lot of processes
that map into that portfolio, right?
So, you have work that's coming in.
You need to triage or manage that process
or go through an approval process.
And that requires a lot of human oversight
and manual processing and manual checks.
And that's just a lot of time
that you're spending to do that.
And that's the time that
you're not spending,
actually doing the project
delivery work, right?
It is extra time that gets consumed
and you're not being able
to maximize your capacity.
And speaking of capacity,
if you think about,
if you're, I've talked to
a lot of customers where,
actually I was just on a call
earlier today with a customer
where they had three project managers.
And how many projects do
you think they're managing
at a time across three project managers?
200 projects across
three project managers.
So, their life is just constantly looking
at all these projects, right?
And so, we see this
opportunity to use Agentic AI
to be able to scale your workforce.
If you can do all of those things
you just saw on the previous slide,
if those things are
happening in the background,
then you can scale out.
You can actually manage
such a large portfolio
with a smaller workforce, right?
And you can then begin
to take on more work
and scale out your capacity.
So, that's what we see as the opportunity.
That you can go from
getting those insights
and that those insights
then drive specific actions
that you can perform.
And those actions
are not just necessarily
things that you are doing,
but you can actually then have the AI
perform those actions on your behalf.
And then, the second part
is by being able to apply AI
to those automations, to those workflows,
you can scale your productivity.
So, you're spending less time
doing those manual checks,
manual approvals, manual triage,
or having a human at
different stages of a process.
You can automate the
entire end-to-end workflow
and save time.
And like I said, scaling
out your workforce
by having these agents that are performing
a lot of these duties on your behalf
and you basically have doubled or tripled
or quadrupled each
project manager's capacity
within your organization.
So in the end, what this really means
is with all of this data, if
you can't see what's going on,
you're not gonna be able to manage it.
And so, our mission here
is to give you that insight so that this,
through a project management
tool powered by AI,
you have that broader horizon view
out across everything that's going on.
Not only current state, but
past and predictive future.
So, let's talk a little bit
about what that looks like.
We are calling this
Intelligent Work Management.
And it's an evolution of when we think
about collaborative work management.
It is intelligent and powered
by AI at the very core.
And to support that at
the foundation is data.
You have to have really good data.
And a collaborative work
management tool like Smartsheet
is a place where you can have
that shared source of truth,
whether you're managing
projects directly in it
or you're integrating with other tools
or bringing in tickets from Jira,
or whatever other tools you're using
for managing kind of day-to-day work,
that you have this source of truth
where you're getting a sense of everything
that's going on with the portfolio.
And we are building, have
built a knowledge graph
on top of that data that
you have in Smartsheet.
And what that knowledge
graph does is it analyzes
the connections between the people
and the content and the work,
and uses those relationships
to provide powerful context for the AI.
So, today in Smartsheet there are a number
of AI capabilities we
have already launched.
And so if you are currently a
customer, any show of hands,
is anyone currently a
customer of Smartsheet?
Okay, a couple.
You don't count. (laughs)
So, you have these abilities
to use natural language
to generate really powerful formulas
that can calculate different
things like budgets and risks.
You can generate charts
by asking it questions
and you can convert those
charts into dashboards.
Where we're going though
is rather than thinking
about individual AI features,
we are thinking about, like I said,
this Intelligent Work Management platform
and that works across
the entire lifecycle.
It's a foundational piece
across every part of the
app that you're using.
So, whether it's from setting a strategy
all the way through to
execution and delivery,
you're using AI processing
to improve planning and prioritization.
You're intelligent optimizing plans.
You're continuously monitoring execution,
and then reporting out on that delivery.
So, what does that look like?
Here's a few examples.
I'll walk through it.
And you'll see kind of along the bottom
kind of how we're going
through that journey.
That end-to-end life cycle, right?
You start with just being able to define
what is it we're gonna do?
I was talking to a customer
where they talked about
how they were spending weeks
or even months sometimes
just developing a plan
before they even know
that they have the capacity
to take on that plan, right?
Where they have to figure out like,
what are all the work items we have to do,
what's the resource capacity to do that?
And that's a ton of time.
And then that goes into planning,
and then it might not even get approved,
or it may not meet the bar for
work that gets actually done.
We see an opportunity to
leverage guided prompting,
templates, and document
extraction and processing,
so you can take, you can say,
"Here's a project brief
I got from a client,"
or "Here's a statement of
work that I am working on
and here's some instructions.
And also, can you pull in best guidelines
for this type of project
and use this template
that we have designed as the
way that we work in Smartsheet.
Take all those things and build out
a fully functional project plan,
dependencies, timelines,
everything in minutes.
And that, as opposed to doing
all of that legwork manually
over several weeks.
I forgot to mention that that capability,
there's an early version of
that capability already live
in our trial experience.
So if you go sign up
for a Smartsheet trial,
you'll get a pre, not the document piece,
but the other parts.
And we're bringing the
document part of that
to all our customers in the near future.
So, the other piece we
talked about is like,
once you get all those projects in,
you have these proposals,
you're trying to triage that.
Like, how do you prioritize that?
Again, that's a lot of manual processing,
but sometimes there's
ways to look at like,
can we just do an analysis of like,
the budgets and the costs and the,
is it aligned to an OKR
or a program that we need to deliver on?
And we are bringing AI-powered columns
that are processing data
directly in your sheet using an LLM.
And that allows you to do
kind of nuanced analysis.
So you can do a sentiment analysis,
summarization, extraction, et cetera.
Imagine performing any kind
of LLM prompt-based capability
and automatically
running that on every row
in your portfolio intake.
The really exciting thing
is once you have all of
these prioritized items,
you can start to think about like,
"Okay, what does the
future of that look like?
What does that roadmap look like?
Do we have the capacity
to take on that work?"
Right now, we have in beta a capability
we call Scenario Planning and
it is a Portfolio Level view,
It is a view of all your resources,
all your projects side by side.
And you can see in real
time how shifting work out
is going to impact the capacity you have.
And we're gonna layer
onto that AI capabilities
that will then kind of build
up different scenarios.
So, it could be if I optimize
for balancing my capacity
versus optimizing for cost
versus optimizing for timely delivery,
I can map out different
scenarios and compare those
and have a really data-informed decision
about what we're gonna work on
across our roadmap and portfolio.
So, once you have that work going,
you've decided you've
prioritized the work,
you've got a bunch of projects in flight.
How do you know things
are going well, right?
Like that slide I put at the beginning
of the word cloud, right?
All those, all that work to
kind of just track things
and get things up-to-date,
get people to update things,
and connect to things and
understand the state of things.
We are bringing what we call
a Smart Assist experience.
And this is an AI Copilot experience
that is tuned for Project
Portfolio Management
and it allows you to
do things like analyze
for risk within your project,
get summaries of recent activity,
create executive summaries of progress.
Like a progress report
that you can share out
with your executives and be
able to do all those things
just in a few seconds and
across multiple projects.
So, here we're seeing it in
the context of a project.
We also plan to bring this
to a Portfolio Level view.
So you can imagine instead
of a singular project,
I'm asking if these types of questions
across my entire portfolio
or a subset of my portfolio.
The other part, like I said
is keeping track of those updates, right?
So, Smartsheet actually has a lot
of really powerful capabilities
to remind people to update things,
to pull in updates from different tools.
And this Copilot can automate
a lot of that process.
So for example, here
we're seeing, you know,
build me a daily scrum or sorry,
a daily standup where it's gonna,
it's basically aggregating
people's updates
directly from whether it's Slack or Teams.
It's summarizing those,
highlighting risks,
pulling those out, sending
you a summary update.
And you're able to, you know,
not have to go do that
drudgery work, right?
Of collecting all the information.
It's doing that for you
automatically in the background.
And when we think about
combining those things, right?
Automated actions plus the
kind of risk project expertise
and risk analysis and all that,
we are bringing those
together into agents.
And agents then can perform
a lot of that work for you
in the background automatically.
So, rather than you going
to log in to Smartsheet
and saying, "Hey, what's
the risk in this project,
this portfolio?
It is continually monitoring
that in the background,
looking for changes to the risk profile
of different projects,
doing heuristic-based analysis of like,
how urgent is that risk?
Is it really a high risk or low risk?
And then sending you
alerts and warnings here.
So, this little demonstration is showing,
like a project manager getting
alert in Microsoft Teams.
That there's a resourcing
risk within their project.
And so, they don't even have
to be logging in and monitoring.
It's monitoring it for them.
It brings them in,
shows them some options,
gives them opportunity to reassign work,
address that risk, take action,
and it can actually perform
the action on their behalf.
And this is my favorite part here,
where at the end of that it's
also maintaining a raid log.
How many people know what a raid log is?
A couple people.
Okay, so it's like risks,
actions, decisions.
This is a great way,
it's a good project management practice
but it takes a lot of diligence,
and to remember to do that every time.
Like, oh, this changed
or we're gonna log that.
So, the agent can track project changes
like when dates shifted,
when risks got occurred,
actions were taken,
and it's maintaining
this raid log for you.
And that is gonna help inform
continuous learning and
improvement over time.
And so, when we think
about how that portfolio
lifecycle comes to a close,
if we've successfully
delivered on the project,
you know, projects never
run perfectly, right?
So, you have those learnings,
you have those raid logs,
you have the data that's been collecting.
Again that's feeding back into the data
and into that foundation
of what's happening with,
across your portfolio.
We can start to run analysis
on patterns and trends
that are happening across your work.
So, we can use, like, for
this example is saying,
"Hey, we've noticed this common pattern
within your portfolio
where you have this issue
and we are recommending
based on best practices
and other customers who
in similar domain as you,
that they have implemented this practice
within their project management solution.
And through, because we have
the ability to deploy changes
to your solution design
for your portfolio,
you can immediately
deploy those changes out
even to projects in flight
and make those changes.
So, you're continuously improving
the work that's going on."
All right, so bringing
it all back together.
We'd look at the project
life cycle, right?
From setting the strategy
through execution,
all the way to delivery
and looking at that across the portfolio.
This kind of a little bit
of a mess of a diagram here
is showing how we walked
through those stages
and you could see how agents and AI
are powering each stage of that process,
but at the end of it,
you're getting these postmortem learnings.
So, yes, you're getting value on day one,
but the idea is that
all of those learnings
are feeding back into that
data into virtuous cycle.
So, every time you go through this loop,
you are increasing the knowledge
that the knowledge graph has.
And that that is improving
and increasing the level
of sophistication and insights
and tailored to your business
so that you are continually improving
and increasing the efficiency
and throughput of your portfolio work.
(attendees chattering)
All right.
Well, I can't really talk
about this unless I mention AWS
'cause we're here at the
AWS conference, of course.
So, how is all this working?
So a lot of this that, that I showed you,
some of it we have that Smart
Assist Copilot experience
is in private beta for
some of our customers today
and is coming out to our
Early Adopter Program later.
Those other capabilities
are in development
and all of that is built
on AWS as a foundation.
So, we think about these,
I've kind of grouped this more
into like conceptual layers
to think about at that
foundation is that data, right?
We have that knowledge graph.
The knowledge graph is being
powered by Amazon Neptune.
We have, we are building
conversation history
and long-term memory.
And that is using a Postgres SQL database.
We have, we're building out a data lake,
so we are aggregating and
collecting all of that data
and bringing that together.
And that forms that data foundation again,
that you're recycling through, right?
On top of that, we have agent tools.
So, these are the actions
that the agents can perform, right?
And these are both
tools that are available
inside the product so that the agent
is running those tools
within the project that you're managing.
But we are also gonna be exposing those
through an MCP server that
allows you to access them
through external AI services.
And those agent tools, we
actually started this process
before AgentCore was a thing,
or at least before it was available.
So, we've built a lot of this,
some of this are kinda
from scratch, right?
And right now we're going
through that evaluation of like,
oh, maybe there's a way
that we can leverage
a lot of the capabilities that
just got announced here today
or this week.
So, we're currently evaluating AgentCore
as part of that experience,
specifically AgentCore
runtime for these tools.
Then you have the Agent
Orchestration Layer.
So, this is where we
have different sub-agent
that are specialized, right?
You have a sub-agent who is tuned
to understand resource management.
There's another sub-agent who is tuned
to look at risk profiles
and evaluating risk.
And those sub-agents then are,
we're using Amazon Bedrock
and the Claude models
built into Amazon Bedrock,
and using the Strands SDK
to then build and define
how those agents are operating.
And those agents then deploy those tools
as needed to take action.
So, we talk about this
as insight to action.
So, the agent is monitoring,
looking for risk,
looking for challenges,
identifying like stale data
or missing data, and then
deploying these tools
to take the appropriate
action to fill in the data,
get updates, flag risk,
change resourcing adjustments,
et cetera, to take action on that.
And then, on top of all of that
is a responsible AI layer, right?
So, this is governance across all of this.
Like, you can't just
have the AI running wild.
You need to be able to observe
exactly everything it's doing.
So, we have guardrails, which is managing
like moderation of inputs and outputs.
You have OpenSearch to
track logs and auditing.
So, there's full
traceability and auditability
of all the actions that
are being performed.
And we have an administrative
layer experience.
So, our Smartsheet admin experience
has data access controls,
user access controls
and feature enablement/disablement,
and overall auditing across
all the actions across,
not just, you could actually
have multiple portfolios
operating within Smartsheet
and you can observe that
at the administrative layer.
And so, what does it
mean that we have tools?
Talk a little bit about that for a second.
We are building all of these out today.
We have, you'll see
kind of a gradient here.
The tools that are full opacity
as it were on this slide
are available as part of
our Smartsheet experience,
and we're continuing to add to those.
So these are, again,
are gonna be available
inside the product.
They enable a lot of
capabilities inside the product,
not just existing features but new ones.
And we're gonna be enabling those
through an external MCP server
so that you could take advantage of,
you know, for example, being able to call
a Smartsheet agent
externally through the MCP
to perform actions on your behalf.
And when we think about responsible
AI on that layer on top,
really there's kind of four
principles that we see.
Data privacy and security.
So, that's that control accountability.
So, that's being able to like,
see everything that it's doing,
that you can govern every
action's being performed,
transparency, explainability,
understanding each action,
why it's recommending actions,
and why it perform that action.
And then making sure
that it is providing fair
and reasonable responses
to everything that you're inputting.
So, let's wrap it up.
It looks like I'm out of time anyway.
So, the future of portfolio management
looks like this, right?
From hours spent building
out project plans to minutes,
turning a doc straight
into a working project.
From stuck processes to
intelligent end-to-end flows.
From manually tracking down,
you know, hounding down
a particular person,
you have agents automatically
updating, tracking,
and responding to stale data
or updates that are required.
And instead of just the status quo,
you're getting this continuous, virtuous,
continuous learning and virtuous cycle
of new insights that are feeding back in
and you're improving
your process as you go.
And that's it. Thank you very much.
I really appreciate it.
You can come visit us,
learn more at our booth.
I think it's 586.
Yes. Perfect.
And if you wanna scan this QR code,
this will take you to learn
more about our features,
AI features, and our white paper.
- [Presenter] All right.
Thank you very much.
- [Olen] Thank you.